we have a voicemail today which is an
unusual voicemail and it's a voicemail
that was impacted as you'll hear by not
one but multiple substances that can
sort of impact inhibition so let's put
it that way to 192 david p is our
voicemail number if you want to leave a
voicemail let's take a listen to this
caller hi David this is John from Mojave
California I was wondering if you could
be some other race or ethnicity which
one would you want to be
I must confess I've been drinking and
smoking cannabis tonight the question
popped into my mind I usually have
strange questions like this but I
thought for myself I would like to be
Mexican I don't really have an answer
for that but I think it's an interesting
question yeah thanks for your time so
Mexican is obviously not a race Mexican
is a nationality you're talking about
somebody who's Latino you know it's
never occurred to me to think of what
other race I would want to be it really
hasn't yeah I mean I feel like I could
come up with some clever answer to this
question but you're kind of walking on
eggshells when it comes to this topic so
I'm just going to stay out of it if it
didn't you told me off air you want it
to be a Mizrahi Jew that was the a
yesterday you want it to be well I am I
this is kind of spoiling our ancestry
DNA results yeah but there's a low
confidence chance I think of like less
than 1% that I'm Eastern Jewish right
Eastern European Jewish yeah Pat clearly
not Jewish because Jewish people would
never use the phrase Eastern Jewish like
Eastern Airlines Eastern Jewish okay so
anyway clearly a voicemail that was
indeed influenced not only by alcohol
but but also cannabis as the caller
suggested okay on the bonus show today
students left the pineapple in the
middle of an art exhibition and people
thought it was part of the exhibition
the heart bypass turns 50 years old and
this relates to my birth country of
Argentina also I will follow up about
the just horrible double murder that
took place
within blocks of my apartment in Boston
and there is news about that david
pakman.com slash membership that's how
you sign up for membership and get
access to the bonus show you can also
make a pledge on patreon at patreon.com
slash david pakman show